[music]
panipani
cnd The youngest ever Shogitai Today's title folder
I became a dragon king It was an elementary school girl who set out to receive Kuzuryu and Ichi
I went to get it done as promised hame
I'm so happy I don't remember I had
completely forgotten about that promise, but I thought I'd make a suitable opponent and have them go home In the game, I caught a
glimpse of the amazing talent of the Ainu
This child has uo's voice  We're seriously coming to the cross
Let's do it
There are a lot of people around us who are connected by
shogi Women's triple crown Sora Ginko
My Shosei Taki and her daughter k  In addition to that, my
best friend Kannabe im and other rival models, etc.
Mitsuha-chan, Nana-chan, and Choi-chan, who became friends at the Shogi Kaikan where I was taken to for the first time, formed a shogi study group.
We will study together and do our best to become stronger together
.